La Dolce Vita with Alfa Romeo the most
Italian of car brands the company was
founded in 1910 and has a varied history
this 6c 2500 SS dates back to the middle
of Alfa's hundred year history it's a
car that combines pre-war motor
technology with the aesthetics of the
early post-war era Alfa started
producing the 6c Series in 1927 and the
model was continuously updated until
1953 to keep up with the times
6c stands for Sasa Lindley six cylinders
this 1948 6c already had a two and a
half liter engine and 110 horsepower
right from the word go the engine was
equipped with dual overhead camshafts
but a special cylinder head is only part
of the Alfa Romeo story the kawari
sportivo is as popular today with
Italians as it ever was
walk upload see who's a specialist an
Alfa Romeo says he's been driving and
repairing them for more than 30 years he
grew up with them
his uncles all drove Alfa Romeos and he
was even driven to school in one he
praises them especially as a great Drive
saying they have a fantastic sound are
very fast and have a long tradition this
6c got it's bespoke bodywork from the
touring company in Milan and even took
part in the Mille Miglia today it's
estimated to be worth around half a
million euros
alpha-male enthusiasts helmet lockup
explains that the 1948 model was given
new bodywork after the war although the
construction dates back to before the
war he says these cars were often given
these sublime kinds of bodywork like
this
2500 as as Super Sport with its short
wheelbase only 20 or 23 of them were
ever built
they were the direct forerunner to the
villa destined and Locke camp describes
it as one of Alfa Romeos crown jewels
still today at least where the six
cylinders are concerned although the
bodywork is constructed from aluminum
making it super legit the large alpha
feels heavy and it's steering takes a
bit of getting used to its pre-war
vintage workings mean the driver needs a
sensitive touch when it comes to
switching between its four years
but after you've mastered its
idiosyncrasies few would refuse to take
this car perhaps the most beautiful of
all Alfa Romeos
on the Mille Miglia with its Art Deco
dashboard a nostalgic Flair que bella
machina